bolt is a right-handling company just
like uber you can book a taxi through
them now you can also rent electric
scooter or have your groceries or your
takeout order delivered you can even
book a rental car through them and bolt
is mainly competing with Uber in Africa
and in Europe
there are a couple things that stood out
to me about bolt and Marcus Village when
I started reporting on this story Marcus
was unusually Young when he started this
company he was only 19 years old so what
I saw in Marcus Village and bolt was
something that best of David and glass
story you have a much smaller startup
and a young founder
going head-to-heads against a much
larger a much better resource American
rival in the form of uber people also
play very very tough we're seeing Marcus
and bold at times winning despite the
odds being stacked against them
starting any business is hard but it's
especially hard if you're starting as a
19 year old kid in a small country like
Estonia with very limited experience and
funding so the first months were brutal
I was coding the app myself during the
summer I was going on the streets of
Thailand signing up taxi drivers one by
one and 90 of them immediately said get
out of my car you're just a young kid
where you can offer me it makes no sense
so it was very very tough and it was
just persistence and very hard work that
got us to where we are today
the Bolt's grown very quickly in recent
years and today is raised 1.8 billion
dollars for Venture capitalists at his
last round last year that valued the
company at 8.3 billion dollars but when
we look at corporate filings for 2021 we
can see that they generated around 570
million dollars in Revenue how does that
compare to Lyft or Uber on a revenue
basis that means that bolt is around
five times smaller than left or around
50 times smaller than Uber
really grew up in Thailand the capital
of Estonia it's a small European country
on the Baltic Sea in northeastern Europe
he founded this business right out of
high school so he had a few
entrepreneurial Ventures beforehand he
was web designing and he started a small
sort of edtech app I'm gonna quickly
realize it'd be very difficult to scale
that and sort of started looking around
for sort of new ideas New Opportunities
and I think a big inspiration was Skype
Skype was estonia's kind of pioneering
unicorn startup that created a pre-zoom
online video an online call-in software
that ended up being acquired by
Microsoft several of his early investors
came to Skype and his older brother
martin who helped co-found the business
and also worked at Skype as well
Estonia actually has an interesting
background where due to the Russian
occupation for 50 years all
entrepreneurship was outlawed so nobody
could start the business and that was
the environment that was first growing
up in but also of course as soon as the
occupation ended and the stone again its
independence everybody wanted to start
something new so actually starting a
company seemed like a very popular new
trendy thing to do and what also
happened was there was no other big
companies to join because the economy
was so new so it wasn't like you could
go and join a large corporation with
many young people exactly wanted to do
or start their own business so it was
actually a pretty natural environment
for me to grow up wanting to be like
that as well Marcus talks about having
been in to see many of the kind of
leading Venture capitalists across
Europe and Beyond and was met with the
same answer no thank you investors were
intrigued by him and what he builds but
when they were looking at the obscenity
of this very young founder from this
very small country to build a product
that could compete with Uber was already
raised over a billion dollars investors
were not optimistic his prospects as a
result of that monks had to learn to do
things his own way on a very small
budget this meant that Marcus and Bowles
had to find new ways to grow and had
find Smart solutions to do that and to
beat Uber some of these examples would
be looking at Africa where Bob was very
quick to offer cash payments this meant
that you could book a taxi through the
bolt app and instead of making a payment
via Apple pay or with a cards you would
hand your driver cash and the driver
would settle up with bolts at the end of
the day or the end of the week
this may sound like a small thing but
around 25 of people in South Africa
don't have access to a bank account or
credit cards and that's even higher in
other parts of Africa where bolt
operates
I'd say the hardest part of our journey
so far were the first five years
because we were barely able to raise any
funding at all we managed to raise about
1 million euros and then we built the
company into more than 10 countries with
that limited amount of funding while our
competitors were raising more money than
any company in the history of technology
so we were completely completely
outspent by all these other players and
the only way we could succeed was by
being smarter so we were really focused
on making sure that the team is very
focused on frugality and we count really
the impact of every Euro that we spend
is a common playbook for startups in
Europe that as soon as you start to
build some traction you should go to the
US which is the largest possible Market
however Marcus was relying on his own
data there he started looking at the
stats and saw that the greatest possible
potential was actually in Africa
specifically in South Africa rather than
the US he also knew that you'd face less
competition there than he would do where
he had to go head-to-head with Uber or
Lyft in the U.S market you need to
expand only to the cities where you can
actually offer something better than the
incumbents do otherwise you're just
generating no value there so we realized
very early on that Central and Eastern
Europe was underserved other platforms
didn't really understand the local
customer as well as we did and that
translates into many things for example
local payment methods they didn't work
with all the drivers in these markets
they didn't necessarily focus on safety
and some other aspects that were
important here of the years of running
Bolton a very tight budget Marcus was
available in the pandemic to raise some
really large sums of money from
investors that's supercharge the growth
of bolts and help to expand into new
areas like scooters like food delivery
like groceries and even offering rental
cars must be really expensive e-scooters
are a tough business though investors
around the world have invest around five
billion dollars into startups like bird
but many of them still don't earn profit
and aggressively burn in money most
companies can barely build one product
that reaches millions of customers and
even less companies are able to actually
build multiple products that ever work
really well so we were always very
conscious that we don't want to expand
into products that are not centered
around or core Mission but with electric
scooters we realized very early on that
there's many synergies that we can
benefit from by having the leading
retailing service in the city and by
also having the leading scorer sharing
service in the city because it's largely
the same customers anyway so we don't
need to spend nearly as much money on
marketing to acquire those customers but
we can take that money the data company
spend on marketing and actually invest
that into having a better product and
cheaper prices
Paul's Mission from day one has been
that we want to build better cities and
we believe the best way to do that is to
replace private cars so it's never been
that we only want to be a right-hand
company I don't even have a driver's
license so for me it was always how do
we expand the the product sets so we can
truly replace the private car and the
electric scooters were the next obvious
place for us to expand into because most
of the trips and cities are short and
the electric scooters one of the best
ways to replace those trips
right handling is a tough business it's
hard to make money here with very tight
margins Bolton's got a lot bigger but
the business also burnt through 600
million dollars in 2021 and investors
will be watching Marcus's and Boltz
numbers very closely but also Uber and
Lyft which have still yet to turn our
annual profit
our mission is to make cities better by
replacing private cars and we think that
we're truly at just the very early
stages of that we already have more than
100 million customers across Europe and
Africa but when you look at the
potential then we think there's more
than a billion people that we can
address over these two continents over
the next 10 years to come
thank you
[Music]